it doesn't make me feel
too good when people say forecasts are
always wrong especially when i know
they're mostly right so remember that
next time when you look at your phone
and it says it's going to be sunny and
then it rains
you probably should have watched me
[Music]
hi wired i'm janice huff chief
meteorologist at wnbc-tv new york
i'm here to debunk some common
misconceptions about the weather
tornadoes cannot cross water sure they
can
tornadoes can hit cities they can cross
water and they can cross mountains
remember that the united states is
mainly a rural country
we have cities and large metropolitan
areas but there's more
countryside than there are big cities
and so we don't
hear of tornadoes hitting cities as much
because they mostly hit rural areas
how far does a tornado travel well that
varies
most tornadoes are small and weak but
some of the bigger tornadoes can travel
much
farther we call those long track
tornadoes and the longest track we have
on record
is the great tri-state tornado of 1925
which traveled from missouri
to illinois to indiana over 200 miles
one storm most of the tornadoes that
happen around the world
happen in the united states and the
reason why is because
we almost have the perfect setup for
tornadoes to develop
which is right in the central portion of
our country in the southeast
where warm moist air from the gulf of
mexico meets up with cold dry air
from canada and very dry air coming in
from the western states
when all of those ingredients come
together you get big supercell
thunderstorms
one of the things you might look for in
a thunderstorm if you're outdoors
to notice or see if there's a tornado
would be rotation in the clouds
oftentimes thunderstorms supercells that
produce tornadoes
are actually rotating clouds you may
start to see
a little appendager on the back end of
the thunderstorm the wall cloud sort of
separate itself or at least drop down
from the back of the cloud
if that starts to rotate and you start
to see a little funnel forming
then there's your tornado you don't
always see it that way
but it often happens that way tornadoes
have hit every state in the united
states
so always stay aware when there's severe
weather lightning doesn't strike the
same place twice
actually lightning has struck many
locations more than once
like the empire state building even
people
roy sullivan who was a park ranger at
shenandoah national park in virginia
was struck seven separate times
and live to tell about everyone now the
chances of
you being struck by lightning is about
one in
five hundred thousand but if you're
outside when there is a thunderstorm
and you can hear the thunder that means
there's lightning very close by
so you really should go inside one
lightning bolt is
equal to about 300 million volts of
electricity now your standard household
volt
is only 120 one of those bolts could
actually power one incandescent light
bulb in your house
for three months rain is shaped like
teardrops
not really instead of looking like a
teardrop or a round circle
it looks like a hamburger bun raindrops
start out
usually high in the clouds as ice or
snow and as it falls through a warmer
layer it melts
but because there are updrafts and
downdrafts going on inside the cloud
these raindrops are colliding with each
other to form bigger raindrops
and then they get heavy enough and they
start to fall to the ground
but as they're falling their shape
changes because of the air underneath
they're not shaped like tear drops
so how do we track raindrops
precipitation
snow in our case at wnbc we use an
s-band high-frequency dual polarization
weather radar called storm tracker 4.
dual polarization means that the scan
goes vertical and horizontal
so we can actually get a better idea of
the shapes
of the articles that are in the cloud we
could tell the difference between
raindrops and snow
snow and hail because we can detect the
shape using a sophisticated radar
and that's usually how we track weather
as it's moving across the country
when it reaches your region you use the
radar so you can see it coming
and we can let everybody know here comes
the rain
rainbows have seven colors that's pretty
much true
we see the colors of the rainbow in
stripes but they're actually
not in stripes it's one continuous
change one continuous band
of color rainbows are an actual circle
did you know that
the rain has to be opposite of the sun
in order for you to get the rainbow
and the rain droplets refract or bend
the light the white light that passes
through
and then we're able to see that color
band that bow
a double rainbow happens when the light
is reflected
twice through the raindrops it's not as
intense as the
primary rainbow it's the secondary
rainbow and the colors are opposite too
from the reflections
how do you get a triple rainbow that's
even rarer
but the light has to reflect off of
something else so let's say you have a
rainbow your primary rainbow
and then maybe you have a secondary
rainbow because the light's passing
through
twice but then you may have a body of
water nearby that reflects light again
and then you get another band of color
and then you get a triple rainbow
the weather forecast is always wrong
no it's mostly right the apps on your
phone where you look at that you say oh
the weather's gonna be this that and the
other thing
those apps are good but they're not
great and they're not always the most
accurate because they use raw weather
data whereas we
can use data we use technology we use
our eyes and ears to actually see what's
going on
all of these things help to make our
forecasts more accurate
than just looking at your phone the
atmosphere is like a fluid
it's always constantly moving oftentimes
as you get farther out into the forecast
it may not be as accurate however
forecasts
even longer range ones like maybe out to
10 days
have become more accurate over time with
new technology
there are all sorts of observations from
satellites from
radio signs that are taken up by weather
balloons from buoys
from aircraft all these things go into a
computer forecast
a numerical model and then that will
take all that data that we put in
from the present and maybe from the past
too and then crank out the future
many things that are out of our control
can disrupt weather forecasting
and cause the forecast to maybe be less
accurate like cobit 19
when we had the shutdown back in march
there were fewer planes flying in the
sky
we received data from aircraft that
helped us make forecasts there was a 75
to 80 percent
drop-off in air traffic and that changed
the forecast
what weather patterns are the most
difficult to forecast it depends on
where you live
on the east coast it's probably
blizzards trying to figure out where
that
rain ice snow line is actually going to
set up
for other parts of the country it's
different things on the front range of
the rockies in colorado
they get these down-sloping winds called
chinooks
those things can heat up the atmosphere
or heat up the ground
30 40 degrees in minutes
thanks for tuning in the weather is the
only thing that affects our lives
every day and we have to really pay
attention to it
so remember to stay weather aware so
you'll know
what to wear
[Music]
and that's your weather take it away